All right,
everybody,
thank you so much for coming to talks at Google.
We have an amazing guest for you today.
Adam Brown.
Adam started an organization in 2008 called pencils of promise,
which a lot of you might have heard of.
They've gone all around the world,
uh,
and started schools and impoverished regions.
Uh,
they started over 400 schools to date.
he's actually the New York Times bestselling author of the promise of a pencil
and he recently just started his newest venture,
which is incredibly exciting.
It's trying to basically upend the traditional college system,
uh,
and,
and end the cycle of debt,
teach students practical skills.
It's a one year program.
It's really exciting.
Uh,
and he's here and he's,
that's mainly what we're going to be focused on.
Uh,
can't,
can't wait to have Adam speak.
He's a,
a perfect example of somebody who kind of embarked on a non traditional path
that's purpose driven at a,
at a young age.
Uh,
and he's going to talk about where education is headed and what mission use
place is in that.
And that's,
that's what I just described.
His new,
his new venture.
Um,
so please join me in welcoming Adam Braun to the stage.
Thank you so much.
Um,
so,
uh,
as you heard,
I,
I spent a really the last decade of my life focused on education and both
internationally and now more so domestically.
And so I figured I'd walk you a little bit through that journey and,
uh,
you know,
Kinda open up today's talk,
uh,
with a little bit more context in particular on Missionu and then we can dive
into some questions,
uh,
and then really opened it up to a Q and a with all of you.
So,
uh,
to begin with,
um,
you know,
this is a,
a community in rural Ghana.
Uh,
pencils of promise began in 2008.
I put $25 into a bank account in hopes of building one school.
Uh,
and that first goal was in a rural Laos.
over time.
What I saw was that,
uh,
not only did I have a personal passion for,
attempting and,
and really,
uh,
guiding,
I think,
uh,
communities,
in particular communities of poverty in rural parts of the developing world,
uh,
to enable their future generations of children to gain access to better
education.
But that idea really resonated with a lot of people in particular,
young people across the country.
And so,
uh,
what started in rural Lao screwed in Nicaragua and Guatemala,
eventually Ghana,
uh,
and this was a community,
that I entered with some of our staff.
Uh,
and what we saw was that about 800 people live in this community,
and this was considered the school for the entire village.
Uh,
so you can imagine a,
obviously these children were not getting access to the quality of education
that we would all want for them.
Uh,
and with the support of a,
actually a school in the United States and a Chicago that puts together a peer
to peer fundraiser,
uh,
we were able to raise the funds to go and work with this community directly to
really transform the lives of those children.
Uh,
and it,
you know,
transformed from this,
uh,
into this,
which is what a completed pencils of promise school looks like.
And I spent a lot of time,
uh,
over this last decade going really not only around the country but around the
world speaking about this work,
trying to really galvanize others to get involved in this process.
Unfortunately,
the organization has grown by leaps and bounds.
It's,
you know,
a really found tremendous success.
Uh,
and you know,
the,
the next step for me in 2013 is we started to approach what felt like a very big
milestone,
which was completing our hundred school,
uh,
which actually was in Ghana as well.
Uh,
I decided to write a book about it,
and that book was called the promise of a pencil.
Uh,
what was really important was actually the subtitle of the book,
which is what an ordinary person can create extraordinary change.
And so,
you know,
as much as,
uh,
I felt,
you know,
really inspired by the work that we were taking on,
uh,
my real goal was actually to help other people figure out how they could pursue
their sense of purpose and their sense of passion.
And so the book is framed around 30,
very short chapters.
Each chapter is title with a mantra.
And those mantras were really the guideposts for me,
uh,
as I navigated the challenging waters of,
of figuring out how do you build a,
a global organization from scratch in particular starting in late 2008 in New
York,
which was incredibly challenging period.
Um,
and so,
you know,
that that subtitle,
how an ordinary person can create extraordinary change is what motivated me.
And I found myself,
uh,
on many,
many college campuses around the country.
And you know,
as,
uh,
I would tell this story,
there was certainly a subset of people that would actively get involved.
And,
you know,
they tell their friends,
they tell their family.
And as a result,
this,
this organization continues to grow.
And in recent years.
And as of today,
uh,
we've now built over 400 schools around the world.
We have about 75,000 students in our programs.
And what started with just $25 is now turned into more than $50 million raised,
uh,
to support these children around the world.
But,
uh,
as I went from location to location to location,
really speaking about the,
the value and virtue of this work,
what I found was a common refrain,
a on every type of college campus that I visited,
whether these were elite private schools,
uh,
community colleges and Tennessee and Arizona,
large state schools,
not elite private schools.
There was always this significant subset of students that would come up to me
afterwards or ask a question during Q and a and they'd say,
you know,
Adam,
this is really great what you're describing,
but I can't even consider the type of work that you're describing because one,
I have so much student debt that the number one thing in my life is trying to
get out of that student debt.
And then to a,
I don't actually have any of these skills,
they're going to help me get the jobs that I'm seeking.
And I'm now hearing this as I apply for internships and jobs.
And so I started to do a lot of research into some of these challenges and I
deeply believe in organizational focus.
And so pencils of promise needed stay true to its core mission to support
children in the developing world.
But there was a huge personal transition for me when I met my wife.
And uh,
at the time,
you know,
I,
you start to fall in love with somebody,
you start planning a life together.
And one of those,
you know,
important conversations is to figure out where you're coming from financially.
And what was very clear to me from really the,
the first month that we spent together was that she was,
you know,
from a very loving family but one without a lot of financial means.
And they came to this country and she was nine from South Africa,
moved to the Boston area in hopes of really building a life of,
of success and prosperity.
And you know,
if,
if you're new to this country in particular or your of a working class or lower
income family,
you know,
what's the number one thing that every parent tells you you should invest in,
that you should focus on to get a better life ahead?
Education.
Right.
And I think that's a dream that we've really kind of sold to generation after
generation.
Uh,
on my mother's side,
my grandfather actually was part of the first wave of individuals to get access
to free college in the United States through the Gi bill,
which was passed in 1944 and it really started this movement towards college for
all.
Um,
but you know,
my wife bought into that and she went to college initially out of state after
two years,
transferred back in state to try and reduce the cost.
And after three years needed to leave school before actually attaining that
bachelor's degree that she was pursuing because the,
the challenges were so great financially.
And by the time that I met her,
uh,
her student debt,
was at over a hundred thousand dollars as a result of these three years.
Um,
and,
uh,
it was absolutely crushing.
And eventually as we moved towards marriage,
I said,
you know,
something,
uh,
you should really consider declaring full bankruptcy.
Uh,
you should hopefully,
you know,
I know it's going to destroy your credit,
but I have good credit,
will be okay as a couple.
Um,
and at least to be,
you know,
out of this cage that might keep you in poverty throughout the rest of your
life.
And she said to me,
Adam,
uh,
that sounds great,
but student debt is the only debt in the United States that you cannot declare
bankruptcy on.
And I remember,
you know,
I have a financial background starting my career at Bain.
I've been working at hedge funds since I was like 16.
And I was like,
that's not possible.
Uh,
that's just impossible.
Let me talk to some financial people and help you get out of this.
And of course,
she was absolutely right and I was absolutely wrong.
And,
uh,
as soon as I really discovered that,
I think that in,
in at least my mind,
that's the moment that mission you was born,
that if we had a societal injustice that was this great,
this profound,
uh,
and the one thing that was supposed to enable the people who needed to,
kind of,
you know,
experience social mobility most was going to keep them in those places are worse
than we're creating a greater and greater societal divide between the classes,
which obviously leads us to this huge political division and all these other
challenges that we're now facing as a country.
And so I said,
I need to research this more and uh,
I'll,
I'll show you a chart,
uh,
that,
a friend of mine,
Neil Blumenthal sent me a few months ago.
Neil's the I'm co founder and co CEO of Warby Parker and someone who's also
passionate about this cause he's seeing it on his team.
Um,
some of the challenges,
right of finding work ready talent,
especially out of Undergrad.
And so,
uh,
this is the price change in consumer goods,
over the last 20 years or so.
And you know,
what you can see is that the bottom things like toys,
you know,
new cars,
clothing,
et Cetera,
essentially luxury consumer goods have actually drastically come down,
much more people can access them than ever before.
What you see at the very top is that education has never been more expensive and
even more expensive than traditional education is college tuition.
Uh,
it's risen more than essentially any other incurred fee that someone's going to
take on in their life.
Um,
as I started to dig further and further into this,
what I realized was that,
uh,
not only do you see this huge growth,
the red line in the cost of getting an undergraduate degree,
but the blue line is the average earnings of a bachelor degree holder between
the ages of 24 and 34.
And so that's actually gone down.
And so,
you know,
what we have is one,
the situation where any person who's entering college and his has to take on
debt,
that number is just increasing,
increasing.
And now it's becoming oftentimes insurmountable.
Today's entering freshmen will have on average $50,000 of debt by the time they
graduate,
if they graduate.
Um,
and only,
uh,
you know,
a much lower percentage than we actually anticipate graduate.
Um,
and then to,
they actually don't have the skills that they need,
right?
About three quarters,
believe that their colleges failed,
uh,
to prepare them for the real world.
And so there,
there's three macro shifts,
uh,
that I observed and really 2016 into 2017 and now here we are in 2018 that would
enable a very new model for us to really kind of recreate,
reinvent,
and reinvigorate this very oftentimes a averse to change space of,
of Higher Ed.
And so the first is,
you know,
historically credentials were really the metric for success.
Uh,
people just said,
okay,
do you have a degree?
Yes.
Then you must be skilled because we didn't have all this other information on
individually.
You couldn't search for them on Google.
You couldn't look up their linkedin,
you know,
credentials 10 or 15 years ago.
So,
uh,
we're now we're seeing this shift over to competency based hiring,
right?
Uh,
in particular for technical skills,
you can just put a test in front of somebody and you can assess their technical
abilities.
And that's actually much more important than perhaps,
you know,
whether they have a degree or not.
Uh,
this second is that historically tests were the primary method of learning,
right?
We did rote memorization and then after that rote memorization and then we just
jumped into like an an exam and we regurgitated that.
And that was a demonstration of learning.
And I think that what we are seeing a radical shift to is project based
learning,
uh,
where it's much more replicable to put together a group of projects,
that a person actually navigates through in a group.
And that in itself is a lot more demonstrate of,
of what we actually experience in the real world,
uh,
in our work contest.
And then the third is that in 2012,
we saw the rise of moocs like Coursera and you'd ask city,
there was this huge belief that you're gonna have the best professor in the
world is going to educate 15,000 people.
And that's going to solve the challenges of education.
And what we're seeing is that the vast majority of people,
uh,
don't actually complete those courses.
It's less than 5%.
Most of us are not considered a autodidacts.
So we can teach ourselves and have that motivation and accountability to
complete one of those courses.
And so what we are able to do though is work very effectively in online cohorts
when it's live synchronous instruction.
Uh,
when there's,
you know,
an instructor,
a world class expert in something with a small group and we're held accountable
to those around us on the screen and it's done lie.
That's actually very,
very powerful.
We've seen a few models involved in that space that,
uh,
are able to demonstrate that.
And so,
uh,
and you know,
really it started 2016 I moved from New York after a place in myself as CEO at,
at pencils of promise,
uh,
out to the bay area to focus on building a college alternative for the 21st
century.
Uh,
really reinventing the model of what higher education can and should look like
if you started from today.
Um,
and so I'll show you a quick video a,
it features some really extraordinary people that have gotten behind what we're
doing and it walks you through a little bit through why this works and how it
works.
Did the first time in history the skills you need for work learning and
citizenship have converged.
The current process of academia is failing us in our ability to find great
talent.
There is a gap now in what students are learning and what employees are
expecting in the market.
There's a lack of sort of specific practical experience.
Traditional four year curriculum is missing.
We'll have the technical skills that people need.
They might not have collaboration skills,
project management skills.
They're not prepared to work and you just want to make sure that the experience
that someone has is irrelevant to the job that they have to do.
I'm excited about mission u because the team has been reaching out to folks like
me to figure out what are we looking for in candidates and helping to design the
curriculum around that.
People that take not just ideas and theory,
but they show real concrete examples.
You want people who can work with other people who have great soft skills,
you want hard skills,
right?
The ability to analyze problems.
That's what mission use.
Teaching
the student who's aggressive about taking on things is exactly the type of
candidate we would want to bring in to our company.
Analytical Problem solvers and not afraid of something tough and that's why I
think mission use focus on skills is so important.
It's one thing to learn something in a classroom,
but it's a whole nother thing to have real world experience in a specific field.
One truly lens by doing,
having somebody that's been specifically trained in an area where we need talent
is of real value.
Holding a company,
we set out to challenge norms and so of course we should be empowering people to
do the same thing with their own educations.
We would definitely hire mission.
You graduate,
of course,
I would hire someone from Missionu.
We would a hundred percent higher mission.
You graduate.
Be Very confident about hiring someone from Missionu.
We would and we will hire Missionu grads 1000% I would hire a mission new Grad.
I would totally hire someone from mission unit.
We would like to be the first people to hire a Missionu Grad.
I would absolutely hire Missionu Gretsch.
So,
um,
you know,
mission,
you in essence,
uh,
is this one year program that focused on his aunt real world skills.
And one of the things that we've certainly seen is that it's not enough just to
teach hard technical skills,
but people that really thrive actually possess this whole wealth of soft skills,
effective collaboration,
critical thinking abilities,
um,
effective communication both in written,
you know,
whether it's email or building presentations or in person.
Um,
and so,
you know,
we also thought about what is a,
a actual viable revenue model for,
you know,
a modern institution that aligns itself with the outcomes and the aspirations of
their students from day one.
And so what we decided was that,
um,
before any student ever paid us a dollar of tuition,
we would have to demonstrate to them that they had achieved success,
which is really the exact opposite of what happens on a traditional college
date,
right?
You take out these big loans,
you pay this school,
and then,
uh,
you kind of hope for the best that you end up with a job afterwards.
But their commitment essentially ends when you walk out their door.
And that's when they usually reach out in order to ask for a donation.
And how many people have in that solicitation from their Alma Mater?
Probably all of us.
Um,
and so what we decided was that when someone got into mission,
you,
uh,
we would charge them absolutely no tuition upfront and instead we would invest
in them throughout the course of their entire year at mission.
You.
And,
uh,
at the end of that year,
only if and when they were making at least $50,000 or more,
they would contribute back 15% of their income for three years.
And then that would be the end of their obligation.
And so it's an entirely outcomes based model.
Um,
and we said,
you know something when it comes to designing curriculum,
you know,
most colleges kind of oftentimes are very separated from the business world,
right?
We said,
we should absolutely partner with the business world.
This is what students want.
91% of today's freshmen say they're going to college to get a better job.
And so before we ever started recruiting students,
we were speaking to world costs companies.
Uh,
and they've deeply advised us on curriculum.
Everything that we teach our students goes through the lens of a employer,
partners evaluating,
assessing,
and advising.
Uh,
the second is we would create content.
So we have guest speakers nonstop for our students.
Uh,
they oftentimes go onsite to actual companies to get that real world experience.
So all of our employer partners get first cut at this incredible pipeline of
talent.
And,
uh,
as of now,
these in partners,
uh,
include companies like Spotify,
Lyft,
Uber,
Warby Parker,
Casper,
Harry's,
et Cetera,
uh,
with a bunch more to be announced shortly and hopefully Google at some point as
well.
Um,
and so what I figured would actually be helpful is to walk you through a little
bit,
uh,
of how we've integrated Google's technology being here,
on campus.
Uh,
you guys have been an incredible,
incredible provider,
uh,
of the technology that actually powers a lot of our student experience.
Uh,
we use blended learning.
We think that's really the future of education,
which is a hybrid of both online,
which is live primarily for our students as well as in person.
We think that,
you know,
uh,
a lot of students can learn very well online in particular technical skills,
but those soft skills and those relationships that you create with your cohort
mates really have to be a facilitated in person.
So our students come together at minimum every other week.
A lot of them actually live together because you have to live within 50 miles of
your cohort city.
Um,
and then,
you know,
finally I figured,
um,
uh,
just share a little bit of what are your,
it looks like the first trimester is a deep dive into what we consider
foundational skills.
A mix of both hard skills and soft skills.
A lot of things that come out of Stanford on the soft skill and holistic
development side.
A lot of things that come out of places like Bain,
where I started my career as well as some of the instruction from top data
scientists and our instructors as well as,
you know,
advisors come from places like Harvard and Stanford and Mit.
Uh,
second trimester is a deep dive into your major.
Right now we offer one,
which is data analytics and business intelligence.
Over time we'll learn many more.
And then the final trimester is actually real world work experience,
either internships,
fellowships,
uh,
or consulting projects so that they can complete the year with the actual
competency that they want to enter the workforce with.
So,
um,
you know,
with that,
uh,
I guess we'll kind of dive into a little bit of a conversation,
but,
uh,
if anybody wants to follow up or get involved in any capacity,
this is just my email and I'll,
I'll leave it up there as we chat.
Cool.
Thanks Adam.
Yeah,
thank you.
Awesome.
Really appreciate you being here and for the Google plug.
Um,
so I,
I want to kind of just bring it back for a second and,
uh,
just,
just provide a little bit of context for the audience.
Uh,
talk about,
talk about your child that you talked about,
the inflection point between pencils of promise and mission.
You,
uh,
I,
I'd love to hear you focused on the inflection point between the kind of,
uh,
overachieving,
kind of typical path of like,
you know,
Hedge Fund being,
uh,
to pencils of promise.
Sure.
Um,
you know,
I had a good childhood.
I mean,
a great one.
My,
my parents are amazing.
So now I have 14 month old twins at home.
And so,
uh,
my parents have suddenly never become smarter,
in my life and I've never gone to them for more advice than since becoming a
parent myself.
But,
you know,
they're both very loving.
Um,
my,
uh,
my dad's an immigrant,
came here when he was three,
a child of two Holocaust survivors.
And,
um,
my mother's father passed away when she was quite young when she was about 11.
And so I think that even though we had this great upbringing,
my dad's a dentist,
my mom is an orthodontist and,
and so,
you know,
I don't think that we felt any sense of,
hey were,
were impoverished.
Uh,
but you know,
I'd look around in the town that we grew up in,
which was Greenwich,
Connecticut,
and there were certainly people with way more than what we had.
And,
um,
so I was always aware of that juxtaposition that,
you know,
we were fine,
but there was a lot more to be achieved.
But I think,
um,
you know,
having the recognition that your,
your grandparents lost everything,
including family members,
um,
and every possession in the Holocaust,
there was this kind of mentality,
I guess just ingrained in us.
This is kind of like immigrant mentality of,
um,
you got to work for everything that you're going to go out and achieve.
And so,
you know,
in the teenage mind it was gotten,
make a lot of money and,
and hedge funds and kind of the world of finance was the best way to accomplish
that.
And so that was the path I was on it.
But when I was 21,
I went on semester at sea and just had this series of life changing experiences
through exposure to the developing world.
And I realized,
you know,
the actual purpose for my life is to try and bring as much positivity and
wellbeing into the world as I can.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
enabling others to reach their full potential,
which education I believe does most,
um,
is the path that I pursued since then.
And how would you advise somebody who's maybe in that situation where they're,
they're kind of on the linear path to success to,
to break out of it?
Is it kind of,
you know,
getting out there and seeing the undeveloped world or you don't?
My advice has always been,
um,
that true self discovery begins where your comfort zone is.
And so,
you know,
the,
the surest way to get to that place where you feel most alive,
where you have this deep ingrained sense of purpose,
uh,
is by leaving your current comfort zone.
And for some it's physical,
a relocation,
you know,
go travel.
And you go on a trip to kind of remote part of the world.
But I don't think that's necessary.
I mean in other capacities it's changing the relationships around you.
Uh,
it's changing what your day to day actual kind of routine looks like,
you know,
exposure to new hobbies that you never thought that you'd actually be interested
in.
Um,
all of those things I think help us get unstuck from kind of what we are and
what people in society and norms dictate we're supposed to be into who we truly
are.
Um,
and then the,
the final thing is,
uh,
I think you can just learn from the template of others before you.
And so that means reading books.
I listened to a ton of podcasts and a lot of those podcasts are just interviews.
Uh,
on my way here today.
I was listening to an interview with the founder of Patagonia and it was just so
inspiring for me over the last hour or so,
hearing how different this person's path was and the decisions that he's made
historically.
And it helped me reframe the way that I might want to dictate some of the
decisions in my life as well.
And,
uh,
I want to touch on pencils of promise briefly.
I want to focus on mission you today,
but where it's pencils of promise at,
how involved are you in,
what's,
what's the plan for it going forward?
Sure.
Uh,
so pencils of promise is,
uh,
about 130 fulltime staff globally,
operating in four different countries,
New York being the headquarter,
but the vast majority of our staff is from the countries in which they work.
They're gay and they're loud.
They're,
they're Guatemalan.
Um,
we do have 20 schools in Nicaragua that we built originally.
We decided not to continue expanding their,
so we support that through a partnership on the ground.
Uh,
we had our single biggest growth year ever in 2017,
uh,
which is hugely exciting.
And my role is,
is founder and board Ameritas,
which means that,
uh,
I'm still involved but not on a day to day active basis.
Decisions don't need to go through me,
uh,
in order to be made an executed.
But I tend to be kind of the lightning rod for inbound interest.
People read the book and they'll reach out and then I can funnel those
relationships to the organization.
I still host our annual gala,
which this past year raised a to pour over $2 million in a night.
Um,
so I'm still very involved but not on a day to day fulltime role.
Whereas most of my,
my,
uh,
kind of to day thinking is on
mission.
Yeah.
We have over $1 trillion in student debt in this country.
It might even be fortunately one point 4 trillion,
which is,
which is crazy.
Um,
I remember reading a blog post maybe in 2008 or nine by Mark Cuban actually
talking,
kind of comparing a student debt issued to the housing bubble saying we have an
education bubble because students literally are taking out all this money and
they can't flip it for a profit.
Just like you would flip a home for a profit.
Um,
how exactly is mission you solving this?
you know,
from spending all the time focused on international education?
Uh,
one thing that I've really seen and absorbed is that in order to create systemic
change,
need two things to happen.
Um,
the first is you need innovation,
right?
And that innovation,
if you've read Clayton Christianson's innovator's dilemma,
uh,
it occurs on the fringes,
right?
It's not mainstream.
It's kind of these outside smaller players that start out really small and
they're so small and they're working on something kind of so unique that you're
large incumbents literally don't even pay attention even though if they had
replicated,
they could've squashed them.
And,
um,
you know,
what oftentimes occurs in systemic change is that as that innovator on the
fringe gets a demonstration of success,
what you actually need is widespread policy adoption and advocacy that leads to
a scaled impact.
And so,
uh,
my goal in particular when it comes to mission,
you a,
is for us to be that innovator on the fringe that demonstrate success and then
eventually has policy adoption at the national level.
And then essentially what the US does,
a lot of countries obviously follow.
So a small example would be the fact that we're using a 100% income share
agreement rather than traditional tuition.
Uh,
the fact that we're doing that is putting a lot of pressure on traditional
colleges to respond.
And my hope is I don't expect to see every college be 100% Isa income share
agreement.
But what I do so expect to see is for colleges to be expected to start to have
some skin in the game and eventually for policy to actually mandate that,
um,
you know,
for students not to be required to pay back until they reach a certain
threshold,
which is actually the national policy and uh,
countries like Australia,
um,
as well as this blended learning model to be demonstrated as a proof of one by
us.
There's other companies that are doing it and doing it with great success and
for then that to get adopted by a lot of the mainstream incumbents as well as
policy.
Now you started out with pencils of promise,
kind of focusing on accessibility and getting as many students around the world
kind of educated as possible.
Uh,
Peter Teal talks about the current college education system and he says it's
almost like a nightclub.
Like if you,
if you expand it and allow more people in yeah,
there'll be very angry because basically it's their bread and butter.
Exactly.
Exclusivity.
So how do you reconcile those two things?
Kind of it's this social credential where prestigious,
maybe semi important,
uh,
along with accessibility in reaching as many people as possible.
Yeah,
so,
so
this is a big thing for us and it's currently a,
that we're addressing through scale.
So,
um,
you know,
we launched,
uh,
March,
2017 we said,
we're open,
this is mission,
you know,
and,
and you know,
really had any public exposure to it.
We asked everyone that knew about it to not talk about it until we were ready to
launch.
And we launched March 21st,
2017 and we said,
this is mission you,
you can apply as of today.
And,
uh,
we spend no money on any form of paid marketing.
And we said,
we just want to see organically what happens.
And I did interviews and podcasts and stuff and press picked it up.
But you know,
we didn't know targeted marketing.
So we allow the message to spread to the places where it might spread naturally.
And we said,
you know,
we have 25 spots per cohort.
Uh,
we'll just see how many people apply.
And we had 4,700 applicants for the first 25 spots in about two and a half month
period.
And we said,
oh my gosh,
there's,
there's some lightening in a bottle here.
And our goal is that to be,
uh,
the most exclusive selective higher education program in the country,
which statistically we are right now,
we have a essentially a 0.5% acceptance rate.
Um,
we don't want it to be that.
but we are in at the moment.
So we said,
you know,
one,
we need to go out and raise more capital so that we can offer,
um,
you know,
additional cohorts.
We don't want to change the cohort size.
We think about 25 is the best number for people to build those tight
relationships,
to have the right ratio to instructors.
Um,
but we needed to have additional times in the year when people could apply
concurrently launched cohorts,
uh,
at the same time in the same cities,
expand to new cities as well as offer new majors.
So we went out,
we raised another round of capital from some incredible people.
And uh,
then we opened up admissions for January and we said,
okay,
you can apply for January and we had 5,500 people apply for those spots and now
we're running admissions for May and,
and so,
um,
again,
uh,
we acknowledge that this is a real challenge in higher ed and our goal is to try
and scale quickly to serve that need.
But at the same time,
we want to create a truly world class,
high quality experience for every student.
And we know that we need to start slowly and test out this model.
And once it's really tightly refined on the curricular side,
on the student experience side,
then scale really,
really rapidly.
I mean,
our goal is to serve tens of thousands of students,
ideally be larger than any current college in the country.
Awesome.
Uh,
what does the real world approach me and you guys talk about kind of teaching
practical skills as opposed to maybe more theoretical ones.
Yeah.
Um,
so first of all,
I mean it means having a really tight pulse on what's happening in industry.
Um,
so designing and building curriculum in a vacuum,
having to go through a three to four year accreditation process and then saying
you should go learn this as all of you I'm sure experience on a day to day basis
here at a place like Google is going to leave you well behind what's actually
needed to solve the needs of industry.
So part of it is,
is having these deep relationships with folks,
uh,
ed companies to understand what's needed to actually hit the ground running.
The second is I think a profound acknowledgement that you need to bring that
real world into the curricular design.
And so as I mentioned,
we have our,
I mean,
I went to a great college and I loved my experience,
but I don't think more than once did I ever get exposure to a public speaker who
came in and addressed the class that I was in a,
that actually was working at a company.
Um,
it was so rare.
And so for our students,
I mean,
you know,
last week the global head of,
uh,
artist marketing and Spotify spent an hour just with a group of 30 students and
then that's like on a weekly basis a top tier person comes in and addresses
them.
Um,
but then the second is actually teaching them things that,
that are going to be applicable to getting a great job to navigating their
personal life as well.
So we teach personal finance.
I mean,
how many people here got like a deep introduction to personal finance,
how you actually navigate your financial scenario once you leave the bounds of
your educational experience.
I mean,
everyone's nodding their head no.
So things like that we have,
we have,
um,
you know,
the class will be called success by design,
which is really about finding your internal happiness.
Where do you want to punch your compass in life and why,
you know,
all of those things are I think are applicable to a real world context.
And then finally,
uh,
our students work on projects that are based on real world scenario.
So we'll get,
you know,
dummy data from real companies that are facing a real challenge.
Our students will work through that,
produce a final project,
and then after they ship it,
they can,
one publicly presented as part of their portfolio.
But oftentimes they actually get to present it to somebody who has worked on
that real project at that real company and they get that cycle of feedback.
Um,
and then the final part is just the,
the back third of the years is actually working full time at a great company a
or organization and then getting additional curricular support,
uh,
from us throughout that process.
Yeah.
One of the perks we have here at Google is we get to kind of like speak to
financial advisors and I think this was my first job out of school and like I
didn't know anything.
Yeah.
And I think most people don't know,
right.
They don't know how to flow oneK is,
yeah.
I mean one of the things that we teach our students is a salary negotiation.
And uh,
I remember sitting with a reporter from a major media company explaining that
and she was in her mid thirties and she said,
Geez,
I wish I got that.
And so we think it's important to,
our students range from 18 to 39,
you know,
um,
some of them have transferred in from top tier colleges,
some of them have bachelor's degrees.
Uh,
most of them have some type of college,
but not a ba yet.
And are looking out and saying,
why would I take on this much more debt to get this piece of paper that isn't
actually going to be of greatest value?
Where as mission you will be,
there seems to be a special interest rate now on learning how to learn.
That's actually the most popular course on Coursera right now.
Barbara,
Barbara Oakley,
uh,
teaches it.
Do you guys incorporate,
uh,
kind of,
the most recent,
uh,
kind of neuroscientific findings and findings about just how to learn and how,
how cognition and kind of,
uh,
happens in mission yet?
Yeah.
Um,
this is the obsession of my cofounder Mike.
So,
so is our chief product officer and he oversees both curriculum and technologies
are work cost software engineer as well.
So all the stuff that you were seeing on Google,
he's,
he's overseen and design with Jen who you heard.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
I mean if you saw the slack channels of our team,
like you would just think these people are the biggest education nerds in the
world.
Um,
so,
so yeah,
we obsessed and kind of geek out that stuff.
And then,
you know,
we have incredible advisors like doctor Tony Wagner from Harvard or from,
Oh,
mom froze lecture at Stanford.
And,
um,
so we're,
we're constantly kind of digging into the latest learning science,
you know,
part of that,
uh,
applies into how the actual structure of the program looks.
So for example,
we tell every student,
um,
that,
and so one thing that I'll share is I actually call every student when they get
in.
So the actual admissions acceptance as me calling them a kind of as a surprise
and you know,
they always answer and how he was calling and I say,
it's Adam Braun,
I'm from Michigan.
And then they're like,
oh,
hi,
how's it gone?
What's up?
And then I'll say,
how's your day?
And they say it's good.
And they'll say,
okay,
well hopefully it's a lot better because I wanted to share with you that you got
to and they're all excited.
And then I kind of walk them through,
Hey,
here's the next steps.
Here is your orientation date.
We'll send you a email and rep,
you know,
a repeat,
a lot of this stuff,
so you have it in writing.
But I want to get them comfortable with a couple of the high level details.
And one thing I share is that you can work a part time job while you're going
through our program,
but you can't exceed 20 hours a week.
And that's grounded in learning science.
That shows that if you exceed 20 hours a week of a job while you're trying to
focus on a primary academic commitment,
uh,
your success in that program really falls off the map.
So things like that are applicable for us
and kind of reconciling teaching practical skills and emphasizing that with just
a liberal arts education to begin with.
I can imagine where you kind of fall on that,
but you know,
there are people like Fareed Zakaria who talk about the loss of like liberal
arts education in the country.
I went to Columbia and I'm still trying to figure out whether,
you know,
reading Plato like helps me every day.
But um,
uh,
yeah.
Where do you kind of stand on that?
Yeah,
I mean,
um,
my belief on this is very firm.
I think there's tremendous value in the ideals behind a liberal arts education.
So self discovery,
uh,
critical thinking,
reasoning,
uh,
morality.
All of these things are really,
really essential as part of a formative education.
Uh,
the problem is those things are actually not taught in a meaningful capacity and
the vast majority of liberal arts programs in this country,
what liberal arts has kind of become his general education,
where you're just asked to read a series of texts and suddenly you're supposed
to be expected to achieve these things.
So some schools do it well,
but very few.
Um,
the two places that I think that it's best to achieve our through two courses
that are taught at Stanford,
one is called designing your life.
It's the most popular class in Undergrad,
uh,
at,
at Stanford.
And then the second,
uh,
is called interpersonal dynamics taught at Stanford GSB,
but no one is touchy feely.
And if anyone here has gone to GSB,
uh,
or know someone that's gone to GSB,
this is the course that they will say is the most transformative in their life.
And so we actually have former lectures from those two courses were full time on
staff a admission.
You,
uh,
and our students go through something that is very,
very similar.
Uh,
we call it a I labs are similar to the tea groups there.
And when you mix that with the hard technical skills,
that's actually when you create a really profound transformation in an
individual.
So I think it's important that we incorporate the ideals of the liberal arts,
but that you mix it with the actual a hard and soft skills that will help
somebody get a job right to,
to pay back the debt that they've taken on if they'd gone a traditional liberal
arts school.
Um,
and,
and we really seek to blend that emission.
Yeah.
So is that really how you kind of stay away from being like considered like a
trade school?
Because there are a lot of circles out there.
They're like,
uh,
I don't like my career right now and so I'll switch and I'll go to this school.
And then,
you know,
it's just kind of a pivot.
Right.
Is that how you kind of stray away from that by having these kinds of stuff?
I mean,
I think what we've seen is there's a lot of schools that are out there that are
very effective at helping you get into a new industry and lock in a first job.
That's not our goal,
right?
Our,
our students only send us a dollar if they're successful.
Uh,
you know,
not only in getting the job but they need to be successful for three plus years.
Right.
And,
and so,
you know,
we want to prepare them for an extraordinary life and career ahead.
And part of that is learning this hard technical skill,
but actually a much bigger part is the soft skills and that holistic self
development.
If you spoke to any student that's at Michigan,
you,
uh,
they'll,
they'll say that they needed one to be able to succeed in the other,
that when they really hit that,
that kind of sticking point and learning python or sequel or excel modeling,
it's actually the group discussion that will happen in I lab.
It gives them the confidence and the,
you know,
self awareness to be able to progress through those challenges.
Do you have kind of like a,
a 10 year game plan for a mission?
You,
it seems like right now,
uh,
you might be going kind of the Uber Tesla model where you start kind of premium
and then you'd kind of widened out.
Uh,
what's the,
what's the plan?
Yeah,
so,
um,
one,
I mean,
pencils of promise is in its 10th year.
And if you would've told me at the beginning when I was trying to build one
school and riding my motorbike with a backpack and rollouts by myself that this
year we'd likely break ground in our 500 school,
I would have said that's insane.
And so,
um,
you know,
I think it's challenging to project 10 years out that said,
the,
the ambition is certainly within 10 years for us to be in dozens of cities.
Again,
everyone lives within 50 miles,
so they can come together frequently.
But,
uh,
the 50 mile radius allows for more affordability than just having to be close to
a downtown campus.
Um,
so it will be in dozens of cities will be offering,
I would imagine,
10 plus majors.
Um,
and you know,
I think 10 years from now,
uh,
parents and children,
will essentially look at mission you and I assume others will follow our lead
and create similar types of programs and it will be a real consideration for
every student that you know,
is considering college,
whether they're scratching out of highschool and mid career.
A working adult,
um,
is,
do I go to the one of these traditional four to six years that's a little bit
outdated or do I go through something like a mission,
you know,
and it'll just be part of the landscape of higher education.
And Are you convinced that going forward a classroom is the best kind of medium
or setting to learn?
Um,
I,
I think it depends on how you define a classroom.
So,
you know,
a classroom does not need to have four physical walls around it.
Uh,
if I showed you,
you know,
the engagement of our students,
um,
it looks like a Brady bunch style,
you know,
set of screens.
Um,
our admissions process actually replicates that through a group challenge where
we have total strangers design,
uh,
actually on,
on a Google drive.
Uh,
we give them an ambiguous challenge and then they actually build a presentation
in Google sheets together in 45 minutes and presented to our staffing or call
the whole thing on zoom and go and watch it back.
And so,
um,
you know,
I think that to me is a version of a classroom.
What I would say is a medium through which individuals are able to communicate
in a live synchronous manner,
uh,
with intimacy.
And honesty is the best way to learn.
It's,
it's certainly better than doing it by yourself unless you have a direct tutor.
Um,
so some type of human engagement and that can be a classroom and sorts you and
another person.
Um,
and you know,
I don't think that large lecture halls are the way to do it.
Uh,
but I do think that there's tremendous power in these small group,
cohort based formats in particular behind a screen where everything is being
recorded and where you truly feel accountable.
I want to move on to you briefly before we open it up to Q.
And.
A.
Um,
are there kind of habits or philosophies that kind of helped you just perform at
a high level every day?
I'm sure.
I mean,
this has evolved,
you know,
in,
in my twenties,
it was like just putting in as much work as I can and try and respond to
everything as fast as I can and,
you know,
make the most of every opportunity and like,
I'll sleep when I'm dead.
You know,
that was kind of my approach.
Um,
I think now in my thirties and with,
you know,
a wife and two kids,
uh,
I've really learned the value of self care.
And so,
uh,
for example,
if I work out consistently in a given week,
I out in bike and I play basketball,
then I actually performed much better in the office.
Uh,
if I'm able to meditate for 10 or 15 minutes before the babies are up,
and then my house like goes into,
you know,
all hell breaking loose,
then I feel much more grounded throughout the day.
Uh,
I use an APP called Kaptio,
which allows me to just send a quick notes to myself and my inbox tends to be my
to do list.
And so I try and practice inbox zero or some form of it.
Um,
and then the other I think is just treating people the way that you would want
to be treated,
right?
Building a culture that really values people as people,
not just as numbers on your,
uh,
you know,
excel sheet of headcount,
roadmaps are your org chart.
Um,
and really focus on growing those people into the best performing individuals
that they can and the best people that they can lead to.
A really rewarding work environment and something that you're excited to go into
everyday.
What's your why?
What's the thing that your eyes yeah.
Um,
you know,
my,
my why is quite simply that,
um,
by every statistical measure,
I shouldn't be here,
right?
I mean,
my grandparents were meant to pass away in those concentration camps.
If anyone's read my book on semester at sea,
my,
my cruise ship was hit by a 60 foot rogue wave 800 miles from land.
And we had this titanic esque experience where I was supposed to die that day
and somehow I didn't.
And uh,
so I genuinely feel like this life for me is one in a trillion.
Um,
and so I need to do everything that I can to that,
uh,
and you know,
both leave,
uh,
the most positive mark that I can on as many people as possible.
And now as a new father,
uh,
I realized that at the same time,
I have to balance that with the fact that the greatest mark that I can leave on
the world is producing great children and being a great husband and great father
and siblings.
Um,
so,
so those are the two things for me.
You know,
this kind of big scale of ambition,
uh,
with this very small one that I'm most happy when I'm just hanging out with my
kids and their little bro.
Do you have mentors or role models who have really helped you and affected you
throughout?
Yeah,
I mean,
I've had a bunch of mentors that I've kind of gathered over the years.
Um,
you know,
one of them is a guy named Ray Chambers who,
uh,
is probably most responsible in the world for eradication of malaria.
Uh,
became a billionaire,
really started the leverage buyout space.
And,
um,
I was at lunch and one point with a guy named Randall Lane who was the editor in
chief of Forbes.
And he told me that maybe 15 or 20 years,
and I can remember how long,
but he was,
you know,
not the editor in chief,
but he was running the Forbes 400 kind of lists that as his function at the
company and Ray Chambers is on the list.
And he got to call the next day after I came out and this guy said,
how do I get off the list?
I don't want to be on it.
And he said,
well,
you either have to lose the money or give it away,
but we're going to report it if you're that wealthy.
He said,
all right,
I'll be off by next year.
Um,
any committed his life to humanitarian work.
And so,
uh,
he's,
he's been an incredible mentor.
And then,
you know,
certainly my family members,
I mean,
you know,
my dad,
my mom,
my sister and my brother are there.
They're the people as well as my wife that I talked to most about these
decisions.
Speaking of your family,
have a very high achieving family.
Your,
your,
uh,
Adam's brother actually manages a Justin Bieber among many other artists.
Yeah.
A lot of people.
That's right.
Uh,
do you ever get competitive with scooter about anything you guys took?
Couldn't have taken more different paths.
You're both very impressive people,
but do you ever get competitive with
yeah.
Um,
you know,
as kids we were super competitive.
I think by the time we both had our kind of mid to late twenties,
we realized that we were just operating in such different spaces and the,
the best thing that we can do is just be unbelievably proud of one another and
try and support each other.
I think if you went to a Saturday morning basketball game or where you're
playing on opposite teams,
you would see us pretty competitive.
Um,
but in most things we just try and support one another as much as we can.
Awesome.
Uh,
do you guys have any questions?
Let's open it up for Q and.
A and if you do,
please go to that mic right over there.
Hi.
I resonated with a lot of what you said.
Ah,
thanks for speaking.
Um,
I was wondering if you wouldn't mind sharing with us some things that you tried
or thought that might work but ended up not working out.
Sure.
Um,
I mean at,
at pencils of promise,
you know,
Nicaragua was the second country that we tried to expand into.
Um,
and I'm built a partnership with an organization there.
They kind of showed me the lay of the land.
We sent a small team down,
um,
and it ultimately wasn't successful for two reasons.
The first was,
uh,
the government was incredibly challenging.
You know,
we need to work with supportive governments because we built public schools.
Uh,
the second though was we did this deep analysis and the population density was
very low and the cost of materials is very high.
So we saw it was it was two to three x more expensive to impact the same number
of lives and that country.
Then it wasn't the other,
eventually,
you know,
three to four other countries where we were working.
Um,
and that was really tough,
right?
I mean,
you know,
you starting to country,
you actually make a commitment,
you build 20 schools and then you have to say,
ah,
we're not going to continue to expand and build our own teams there.
That,
that was really hard.
But I think it forced an organizational discipline at pencils of promise.
Uh,
for sure.
You know,
with,
um,
mission you,
I mean,
anyone who likes our pitch deck before there was even a company when it was just
like a seed of an idea would tell you that the way it looks today is remarkably
similar.
There's only been one meaningful change.
And that's that originally we said we're going to have four quarters,
uh,
and those quarters we're going to be hard skills in the first quarter of SEC,
a soft skills and the second technical and the third and then real world in the
fourth.
And we realized right away that you actually can't divorce hard skills and soft
skills that they need to be taught in conjunction.
And so we moved over to a trimester model where that,
that first trimester is a deep dive on the foundation.
Um,
and so a lot of it is,
is like that lean kind of mentality that test and iterate and get feedback from
your consumers.
Yeah,
thanks so much for coming.
It's very inspiring talk and I think this mission you,
um,
concept is a really strong one.
So I guess my general question is this,
this problem of crushing student debt seems to be a uniquely American problem.
And I was wondering if,
if you,
during your research you would look at other countries and maybe could take away
something like either boring stuff that you could incorporate into Michigan you
or are there any,
this is sort of a private sector solution to the education problem and is there
any role for the u s government that's could lead to better informing the
education system or solving a problem?
That one sentence.
Absolutely.
Um,
so,
so right now,
and there's a new bill that's being formed that's probably the most significant,
uh,
restructuring of a higher education funding in the last 40 years.
So they're overhauling essentially the higher education act.
And there's some stuff in there that I agree with.
There's some stuff that I don't,
um,
but I think it directly,
it's actually a move in the right direction.
So one of the things is,
um,
the reason that we're in the position that we're in is a series of factors.
But one of the important ones that the government has enabled is that an
individual can essentially take out an unlimited line of credit at a very young
age without any demonstrated capacity to be able to pay that back.
And we have this society that's kind of,
you know,
encouraged through just societal norms and expectations that you should do that.
And so one thing that's happened as a result is that there's no market force
that's creating downward pressure on how much colleges can charge or any
accountability to the value of that college relative to the cost.
So,
for example,
I can think of many,
not very good colleges that have terrible outcomes that charged the same amount,
uh,
as a school like Harvard.
Right?
And so like me being a car salesman and saying to you,
here's this,
you know,
Lamborghini for $200,000 or you can get this really crappy old beat up car
that's actually not going to drive very well,
but that's $200,000 as well,
and you should buy this one too.
So,
uh,
I think that the government needs to one hold schools accountable to outcomes.
And the best way to do that is through skin in the game,
some type of income share based on student success.
Uh,
the second is to actually realistically put a limit on how much a student can
borrow and when.
I think that will lead to his colleges,
uh,
bringing their prices down.
And the result of that is that a lot of colleges are going to go out of business
because they have on sustainable business models.
And that's actually,
I think,
a very good thing.
Um,
we need to have market forces in place that remove bad actors that are putting
students in positions of peril.
And you know,
just because you're a nonprofit college doesn't mean that you're actually
helping people.
Uh,
and there's a lot that are actually hurting people.
So a skin in the game,
uh,
camping a total amounts that students can,
can,
uh,
can take out.
And then the third is transparency as to how much it's actually going to cost.
It's very hard if you're an 18,
1940 year olds and you're applying to college to actually get the clear
information on how much it's eventually going to cost to you as well as the
outcomes data of those colleges.
It's,
it's very convoluted.
They hide it and Congress needs to really move forward with an effort to ensure
greater transparency in this space.
It seems like there'd be a lot of lot of forces that would kind of be off
operating against those kinds of reforms.
Like colleges are at risk of going out of business.
Definitely.
I mean,
it's challenging because you have one of the most entrenched systems in our
culture,
uh,
as well as our capital allocation in the country.
Um,
but what it's led to is a,
a position that's completely unsustainable.
I mean,
I read a report from the Brookings Institute,
which is as you know,
nonpartisan,
objective and well researched as possible.
That came out last week that projected that 40% of today's college students will
default on their loans by 2030.
I mean,
it's insane.
Um,
so we need to have some type of really meaningful change.
And as an entrepreneur I look at problems like this and I say,
um,
you know,
if not me,
then who,
thanks.
Hey,
thanks for the presentation.
I think the,
uh,
problem that mission use saws,
which is about,
uh,
how to actually deliver education in a system,
which is not exactly a built up for the huge population is slowly going to apply
for the kind of countries in which pencils for promise operates in.
So do you see how technology as as a medium for the instruction can be actually
scaled to developing countries?
And
Oh yeah,
100%.
I mean,
just finished my question.
And,
uh,
what exactly are the challenges that are preventing it from happening as of it?
Okay.
Um,
so great question.
Uh,
one,
when I talk about that 10 year vision,
I mean,
when I say worldly in dozens of cities,
the world,
many of them should be international.
So 18% of our applicants are international.
Uh,
you have to have a visa to work in the u s cause we need to recruit,
raid our investment in new through,
uh,
you know,
livable wages.
And so,
um,
we can't take those students on currently,
but,
uh,
we've had applicants from dozens of other countries.
I recently gave a talk in Singapore about this and the main question from all of
these representatives of different countries was how soon can this come here?
Um,
and so we certainly have ambitions to scale globally.
I think you are right now,
part of the challenge is the ability to deliver live synchronous education over
low bandwidth,
uh,
internet,
but that's increasing exponentially every single day.
Right.
Um,
and,
uh,
so I actually spent the full year in 2015 I was leading the largest,
um,
digital initiative called the global education platform for the UN special envoy
for Education,
which was Gordon Brown,
the former prime minister of the UK.
And in that year,
what I spent,
you know,
observing and seeing was this huge proliferation of mobile,
uh,
across the developing world.
And so what I would see at scale is people being able to actually have these
experiences on mobile in the types of environments where,
you know,
pencils of promise has historically worked.
Hi,
my name is Terry.
I'm from China.
We are facing the same issue in China is not worse.
So I'm shooting spider by your talk today and thank you for sharing your great
work.
My question is simple.
If that model works for mission you,
do you think it might work for high school as well?
Because I see,
I see no point.
Now if we go to college,
peak expensive tuition and they're nothing but high school is preparing for that
entry examination info,
nothing that's that four years,
uh,
greatly wasted.
So maybe we can start younger and without wasting any time and make,
put in Jack Hope in these children's eyes in yeah.
Heights.
Yeah.
I,
I think our curricular approach,
um,
certainly can be adopted about the high school level.
I don't know about the income share agreement because you know,
some people do want to work directly at the end of high school.
Um,
but you know,
I think the curricular approach certainly can be adopted by public and private
schools.
Um,
the kind of product base and certainly the blended learning and the technology
can and should be used in that capacity as well.
Uh,
I mean if the compensation,
I mean,
oh,
the payback part is not only measured by the income,
what else it could be for your success in the school.
Um,
you know,
for us there's also what we would consider nps or net promoter score.
That's actually just as critical in,
in our minds.
We need to create an environment in which our students are the single greatest
evangelists of our program.
And eventually they become really the stewards for additional innovation within
education.
It's what you've seen with teach for America for example,
is,
you know,
they've certainly seen a success.
They've also had controversy but directionally incredible success.
Um,
and,
uh,
not only the success within the schools in which they've taught,
but you know,
there are alarms have gone out and become stewards for an incredible amount of
new initiatives that have had a truly global impact.
And that that for us is absolutely critical to long term success.
Thank you guys.
I mean,
it's really an honor to be here and as I alluded to,
a Google really powers a lot of what we do without even a formalized partnership
in place just by the tools and technology that you all built.
But,
uh,
we're really excited to hopefully build something even more powerful with you
all.
And to the extent that anyone is interested,
please just email me.
Uh,
we'd love to,
um,
whether it's,
you know,
kind of be a case study or even just the Guinea pig for new things that you guys
are developing because we have a team that's really eager to work with folks
like you all to bring a more successful in outcomes driven education to people
around the world.
And we have some books as well,
if you want to stick around and pick those up.
Uh,
everybody please give a round of applause for Adam.
Thank you.
[inaudible].